well I'm here I max and I've seen the
film for the pretty much the first time
in imax the whole way through just now
and it's pretty incredible experience
because you live with the film for a
very long time in a half-finished state
on a very small monitor so to get this
stage of the moviemaking process where
you're actually seeing it in the scale
it is intended to be seen in it's very
exciting because obviously intimately
Alice you have to create enormous world
if a sense of what it could be but
really any when you see it here on a
screen of this size you get the idea of
this is what it was always supposed to
be like
and so that work requires an incredible
amount of detail and detail of course so
I max it really helps that situation for
sure when you build environments or
great environment of that scale it's a
huge amount of work and the level of
detail you put into it is really
incredible you can watch this film and
see locations like times castle the
place is absolutely enormous it's kind
of a it's big on the outside but even
bigger on the inside and so you really
get a sense of incredible depth of this
space this space is obviously all time
ever and so is absolutely enormous
seeing it on the screen this side you
get oh I understand is this in time is
the infinite basically
this one was an adventure and it's an
adventure whereby you're joining with
Alice on this adventure and I think
there's no better way to do that and
then I met